some characters are destined to steal
the show but when it comes time to cast
roles crazy things can happen and it's
impossible to predict who will end up in
front of the cameras when they start
rolling it may be hard to imagine but
some of your favorite movies and TV
shows almost featured someone else
entirely in the leading role here's a
list of roles
everyone in Hollywood wanted to play
young Han Solo casting the original Han
Solo with nearly as tough as making the
castle run in under 12 parsecs
so when Lucasfilm and Disney announced
they'd be expanding the Star Wars
universe with a full slate of standalone
films including a young Han Solo prequel
directed by Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller every twenty-something male actor
in the galaxy lined up to audition among
the big names whiplashes miles teller
angel Elgort from The Fault in Our Stars
neighbor star Zac Efron and Brooklyns
Emery Coen sources claim over 2,500
actors either met with casting or
submitted tapes before hail Caeser
breakout actor Alden Ehrenreich was
ultimately cast in the hotly anticipated
film which will fly into theaters in
2018 just don't get cocky kid of course
that wasn't the only Star Wars role to
be hotly contested ray a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away Lucas um
decided to make a third Star Wars
trilogy and needed a brand new hero to
anchor it directed JJ Abrams and the
casting team launched an extensive
search for the right person to play Rey
the mysterious orphan at the heart of
the force awakens Oscar nominee
Saoirse Ronan additions apparently
having a blast pretending to take out a
lightsaber elizabeth Olsen and shailene
woodley were rumored to have addition
for the part as well but Abrams was dead
set on casting a fresh-faced newcomer
Daisy Ridley NAB's the role after five
auditions including one tearful screen
test that blew Abraham's away the force
is strong with that one Wonder Woman
Hollywood has tried and failed for
decades to bring Wonder Woman to the
screamed along the way quite a few of
the film industry's biggest stars have
expressed interest in putting on her
iconic bracelets including Sandra
Bullock Mad Men's Christina Hendricks
former Bond girl Olga Kurylenko and even
Katie Holmes who's no stranger to the DC
Comics universe when Warner Brothers
finally decided to cast Wonder Woman for
2016
Batman V Superman that casting
description read tall brunette athletic
and exotic Israeli actress gal gadot won
the role and a shot at solo cinematic
stardom with Wonder Woman James Bond
betting on who will become the next
double-oh-seven has become a national
pastime for bookies in the UK six actors
have portrayed the world's most famous
spy on the big screen but every time the
role is vacated a new crop of hot
British actors hope to build bonds
perfectly tailored suits
among those over the years who've wanted
their martini shaken and not stirred
Michael Caine Liam Neeson refine Colin
Firth and Clive Owen current Bond Daniel
Craig has been hesitant to confirm its
participation in another film after the
success and stress of four films in the
role until he does a few favorite
candidates have emerged as these
possible successor Luther's Idris Elba
saw bodies Tom Hiddleston Tom Hardy and
homelands Damian Lewis even x-files star
Gillian Anderson wants to put her spin
on the role who will be the next secret
agent to carry a license to kill only
time will tell
Christian gray and Anastasia Steele when
it came time to cast the big-screen
adaptation of the rhotic vast ella Fifty
Shades of Grey fans of the series as
well as author EL James had plenty of
opinions regarding who should play the
lead roles
fans campaigned especially hard for Matt
Bomer Alexis Bledel
and Ian Somerhalder among others James
was partial to shailene woodley who
passed because of the commitment to the
divergent franchise other names entered
seriously into the mix Oscar winner
Alicia vikander truebloods
Alexander Skarsgard
Cara Delevingne and Oscar nominee
Felicity Jones sons of anarchy Charlie
Hunnam was originally cast as great
opposite Dakota Johnson before dropping
out and being replaced by Irish actor
Jamie Dornan against Hunnam got to
tighter Harry Potter to cast the Boy Who
Lived Warner Brothers put out an open
call on the internet for Harry Potter
look-alikes and over 40,000 kids sent in
addition materials in hopes of being
chosen author JK Rowling's one
stipulation was the cast be British
eliminating Sorcerer's Stone director
Chris Columbus initial choice
stepmoms Liam akin but plenty of other
young American actors expressed interest
including the Six Senses Haley Joel
Osment and Jonathan Lipnicki of Jerry
Maguire fan though he wound up playing
Draco even tom Felton initially
auditioned for the parts of both Harry
and Ron of course now it's impossible to
imagine anyone but Daniel Radcliffe as
the boy wizard clarice starling hannibal
lecter actually never said hello Clarice
in the movie Silence of the Lambs really
and Clarice almost wasn't the Clarisse
we remembered so well had late director
Jonathan Demi had his way though Jodie
Foster campaigned heavily to get the
role she wasn't anywhere in Demi's
shortlist Michelle Pfeiffer was the
first choice having just worked with
Demi unmarried to the mob but she was
uncomfortable with the movie subject
matter and ultimately passed meg Ryan
was also considered thanks to a
popularity coming up two string of hits
but she too passed apparently ascended
Demi even thought of her for such a
gruesome project Laura Dern gave such an
impressive audition Demi said she was it
but Studios weren't comfortable with the
still relatively unknown actress
carrying such a big project so he gave
the roles of foster who went on to win
an Oscar Katniss Everdeen
after the massive success of the Hunger
Games book trilogy there was no shortage
of actresses looking to score the highly
coveted lead role of Katniss Everdeen
Emily Browning best known for her role
in sucker punch and the uninvited was a
top contender for the part so
Ronen who starred in Hanna with Cate
Blanchett was also a strong choice with
a background in hand-to-hand combat and
a pension for athletic roles also on the
list were Abigail Breslin from Little
Miss Sunshine and Hailee Steinfeld of
True Grit of course Cadmus went to
Jennifer Lawrence and the rest is movie
history Amy Dunne anyone who read gone
girl knows the casting for the character
of Amy Dunne had to be perfect
this highly sought-after part was
actively pursued by Natalie Portman
Charlize Theron and Olivia Wilde
Portland the oscar-winning actress best
known for a turn in Black Swan would
have brought a multi-layered performance
while Charlize Theron stunningly
disturbed turn as Mary Ann Lomax in the
devil's advocate with Keanu Reeves
proved she could have nailed this role
alongside Ben Affleck finally Olivia
Wilde no stranger to carrying a film as
the deranged Zoey in the Lazarus effect
had the looks and the chops for the role
of Amy it ultimately went to Rosamund
Pike who turned out to be the perfect
choice Vivien ward for a while it seemed
like every actress in Hollywood was
clamoring to play the hooker with a
heart of gold in what many considered to
be Garry Marshalls masterpiece meg Ryan
was initially offered the part opposite
Richard Gere that had to decline the
offer as she had scheduling conflicts a
string of other actresses merely took
the opportunity to play Vivien but had
concerns with the subject matter
including Michelle Pfeiffer and Daryl
Hannah Julia Roberts ultimately landed
the career making part Michael Corleone
believe it or not Paramount Pictures
first choice for the compelling
Godfather franchise was not Al Pacino
it's hard not to picture him in the
leading role but at one point Jack
Nicholson was wanted to play Michael
Corleone Warren Beatty and Dustin
Hoffman also expressed interest in
playing the role and made it far along
in the casting process meanwhile
director Francis Ford Coppola nearly
pulled out of the project as he fought
paramount executives over casting Marlon
Brando as Don Vito Corleone Batman as
far as Batman movies
Oh Tim Burton's first Batman flick is
legendary in the 1980s every leading man
in Hollywood actively sought an audition
to be part of what was undoubtedly going
to be a hit franchise with a stellar
paycheck can you imagine your favorite
Ghostbuster and Pat man that's right
Bill Murray was reportedly considered
for the Batsuit Mel Gibson was rumored
to as work Charlie Sheen and Alec
Baldwin after all that Michael Caden was
the lucky guy who eventually donned the
cape and cow Ferris Bueller John Hughes
reportedly wrote Ferris Bueller's Day
Off with Matthew Broderick in mind but
other actors had to be considered Johnny
Depp was initially offered the role but
ultimately turned it down Jim Carrey was
also rumored to be in the mix but after
conducting his studio mandated search
Hughes returned to Broderick the guy
wanted to depart all along and in
hindsight it's pretty obvious he had the
right idea dr. evil who doesn't get a
kick out of this super 60 sting spy
comedy up until a scheduling conflict
arose with the production of Wyatt liar
comedy superstar Jim Carrey was set to
play dr. evil in Austin Powers
international man of mystery stuck for
an active to fill the crucial role star
and creator Mike Myers decided to Don
the bald cap and play Austin Powers
nemesis himself Rachel Green easily one
of the most popular sitcoms of all the
time friends catapulted every actor
involved to fame most notably Jennifer
Aniston who played Rachel Green many
young hopefuls auditioned for the role
that eventually inspire one of the most
imitated hairstyles of all time at first
the producers express strong interest in
actress Taylor Leone but as when Aniston
passed on an opportunity at Saturday
Night Live to sign on for the sitcom the
rest became must-see TV history Scarlett
O Hara and may very well be the most
famous casting search of all time in an
effort to build anticipation for the
1939 big-screen adaptation of Margaret
Mitchell's epic novel Gone with the Wind
producer David o Selznick decided to
make his hunt for spunky heroine
Scarlett O'Hara a national obsession
according to an Entertainment Weekly
article he had fans writing impassioned
letters on behalf of their favorite
actresses and a whistle-stop tour of the
south looking for unknown Kalin TTM calm
says that MGM spent two years trying to
cast the role seeing 1,400 actresses and
testing the likes of Katharine Hepburn
Tallulah Bankhead betty davis paulette
goddard and john crawford filming had
already begun on the burning of Atlanta
scene when relatively unknown British
actress Vivien Leigh was cast just days
before principal photography was set to
begin ending a search nearly as
melodramatic as Scarlett herself thanks
for watching click the blue icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]